wait a minute
how does this work let me play a
practice game if I can say my moves that
might be easier computer I'm just gonna
play the engine okay I see this little
thing on top do I have to click it
instructions okay
oh this is so new
use the thing button
to toggle voice recognition perform a
move other commands
E4
wow
wait what I played C4 no
um take the pawn
take it take it yes
take the pawn c c takes D5
oh you're so slow
C takes D5
yes Knight C3
earn the flag
yes
E4 yes
E4
no not B4 take the bishop Knight takes
H3
Knight takes H3
yes
B5
okay let's just
try and beat it
wait what's it hung its king
why can't I move
I'll Pawn B4
where'd that pawn come from
yes let's go
oh that was so buggy
oh oh I was talking
and it was still ah